Facebook is under its closest scrutiny
ever as CEO Mark Zuckerberg prepares to
testify to Congress this week the data
firm Cambridge analytic improperly
obtained private information from as
many as 87 million Facebook profiles the
company will start telling users this
morning if they are affected the data
scandal is causing major financial
fallout Facebook stock is down nearly
15% since the Cambridge analytical story
broke so the company's market value has
fallen by tens of billions of dollars
and some advertisers are turning away
from Facebook Tony de copal spoke to
some of those companies and he's outside
Facebook headquarters in Menlo Park
California Tony good morning good
morning in 2017 ninety-eight percent of
Facebook's revenue the revenue that
helped build this vast campus behind me
came from advertising Mozilla the maker
of Firefox was the first company to pull
its advertising from Facebook following
the most recent data controversy and
while that's only a fraction of
Facebook's revenue right now Mozilla is
also spreading a message of online
privacy rights that could cause Facebook
dearly we couldn't understand it all
there wasn't enough transparency for
years Mozilla used Facebook to tell
people about its products but now the
nonprofit has a new message it's pulled
all advertising off the social network
indefinitely
trust right now isn't being earned
technology companies aren't treating
people like people they're not treating
people like human beings they're
expecting them to have an unreasonable
amount of knowledge about how their
information is being used so Mozilla is
saying that you're uncomfortable with
the consumer surveillance model of the
Internet which is the model we're
uncomfortable with the way that
technology companies are treating people
like fundamentally absolutely businesses
should be able to run using data but
technology companies can't take for
granted that all the things that they're
doing are easy to understand
Mozilla chief marketing officer Josh
aquellas Wolfe showed us how Facebook
tracks and uses your data we choose to
click on this ad when we click on this
ad something happens the data that's
been associated with my profile in the
social media site is turned into a
cookie the data actually follows me
around to every next website that I go
to we've
experience where maybe we've chosen to
buy something I've been thinking about
it and an ad shows up on another site
you see an ad specifically for those
pair of shoes it is a little bit like
you're carrying some baggage it seems to
me like Facebook puts a little bug on
you they're following you a bug or a
baggage really same basic idea no social
media platform is free
David Pogue are a tech ethicist says we
are paying with our personal information
your privacy is a currency every time
you log on to Facebook or any social
media platform you are giving currency
you're just not giving dollars like
Mozilla the home sound company so no
step back from social media platforms
and took a week-long pause from
advertising on Google Twitter YouTube
and Facebook joy Howard is chief
marketing officer at Sonos we thought a
week would be enough for us to take a
pause and take stock of what we could do
to be more a more positive agent for
change in the tech ecosystem Facebook
and Instagram have been a vital tool and
so Knossos success as a company
companies are as dependent on these
platforms as human beings are dependent
on these platforms and there is no
opting out of them especially when we're
in a world in which Facebook and Google
are a duopoly overall add media spending
but ultimately the platforms are only as
useful to us as they are to customers
and so when people start to lose trust
in the in these platforms then their
business value to us diminishes in an
interview with Bloomberg Facebook CEO
Sheryl Sandberg addressed that breach of
trust with advertisers advertisers are
people there are people who use Facebook
so our investors and everyone wants to
know the same thing which is are you
protecting people's data how do you feel
about what Facebook has done in response
to criticism so far it's encouraging
that they're talking about trying to
develop a redevelop trust with the
people that use the product but words
are just that we need to see action and
when product changes happen we'll know
that the message is loud and clear
and speaking of loud and clear more than
a quarter million people have downloaded
Mozilla's new browser add-on Facebook
container it prevents Facebook from
tracking the sites you visit outside of
the social networking site Facebook
tells us it's working with advertisers
to give people more control over the
site and to improve transparency around
advertising Nora Mary Tony thank you I
bet that's gonna be popular with a lot
of people in the news this week
certainly certainly needed and yeah